so if you use what I wanted to notice
now I know you can't do this to your
diagram in fact I don't want you to do
at your diagram but I'm now going to get
rid of the triangles the triangles are
just there to help us get the
coordinates watch carefully once you get
these triangles out of the way oh I want
you to remember what did I do to turn
this guy over here into this guy over
here what transformation did I apply
right I rotated by an alias because I
was trying to work out perpendicular
stuff right so now what a button you can
have this in now what I've got is let's
go purple I've got two lies that are
perpendicular to each other they meet at
right angles right there now remember
you told me parallel lines they have the
same gradient identical one is to the
other is to well here clearly these
gradients are related but they're not
saying obviously they're not parallel so
how we're going to work it out
underneath where you draw this diagram
we're going to work out each of these
gradients we're going to work out the
gradient of a that's the original
interval and then we're going to work
out the gradient or a B that's the one
we got by rotation now remember it's
just right over run rise over run this
one's easy
the first one so a what's the rise you
have the triangle still there it's cute
isn't it isn't it cute it's cute
if I were to be really precise actually
could you take away the earth because
rise is uh what's what is rise it's why
- sorry y2 minus y1 right yeah what
happens no matter what's the run it B
which I get from P minus zero do you
agree so then there's my gradient right
there
q minus beta coming every factor the
left-hand side so OB what is some right
huh
now the rise has through the
y-coordinate so it has to be to do this
P here right but it's not going up isn't
it's going now right so you could either
just say that - P or where does that
come from
it's actually 0 minus P do you see why
because I'm comparing it to the origin
the origins coordinates a zero zero
do you agree so that's that bad that's Y
2 minus y 1 that's that's the great
important what's on the denominator 1 I
think it's 0 minus narrow nobody told me
this guy's on the left-hand side
so actually negative q are you okay with
that you see how it lines it up rise
over run so when I hit the fire the
numerator is negative P what about the
denominator it's positive Q ok now have
a look at these two this gradient and
this gradient
clearly not the same how would you
describe these two how would you
describe them well the lines are
perpendicular the lines are
perpendicular
but the greatest just numbers numbers
come perpendicular to each other only
only shapes can be so what's the
relationship between these I can see two
differences and
you notice they're both fractions right
one fraction is the other one upside
down she knows that we have a need for
that when you turn fractional said that
we call it the this is reciprocal but
they're not just reciprocals of each
other
are they is another difference what's
the other difference not just going to
turn upside down there's a negative sign
thank you so these are negative
reciprocals of each other okay when why
is a parallel their gradients are equal
when lines are perpendicular their
gradients are money people their grading
are negative reciprocals you remember
how I imagine these are p.m. - that
could be anywhere
but we said before it looks like the
gradient of this guy is - what does it
look like the greedy for this is just to
look at it does it look like it's going
to be negative not negative - but isn't
it going to be negative 2 over 4 do you
see
look the rise is going down therefore
negative 2 and the Run is 4 negative 2
over 4 which of course is minus 1 over 2
minus 1 over 2 versus 2 do you see how
they're negative reciprocals of each
other so let me recap pattern Alliance
ingredients perpendicular lines negative
reciprocal gradient is one way you might
find it a little bit easier to take
negative reciprocal a bit of a mouthful
I'm going to say it down the bottom here
and I'd love you to have it underneath
if a is perpendicular to a B if the two
lines meet at right angles
then when you take those gradients the
first gradient and the second gradient
what happens when you multiply them have
a look at the two numbers this guy and
this guy what happens when you multiply
them together
well the Q's cancel out with each other
right it is secured the top the bottom
and then the pin is also careful out
because there's one on the top of the
bottom the only thing that gets left
behind is that minus sign right so in
fact you get negative one
do you remember the exact like is it 2
times negative 1/2 if you multiply those
together sure enough you get negative 1
don't you
does that make sense